من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي لواء فايز مرحبا بك
معنا
هذه الصواريخ نريد ان نفهم منك في حال تم
تزويدها لاوكرانيا
ما هو الفرق الذي ستحدثه في هذه المعركه
الامريكيين في تزويدهم للصواريخ للجانب
الاوكراني اقصى مدى كان 80 كيلو متر
صواريخ هاي مارس عندما نتحدث عن صواريخ
اتكانز
يصل مداها الى 250 كيلو متر اي بمعنى اخر
كاننا نرفع المدى الى القوه ثلاث وبالتالي
ستكون بامكان القوات الاوكرانيه
استهداف
جزيره القرم كامله استهداف مناطق داخل
العمق الروسي
وهذا العمق الذي يمكن ان تستهدفه يعتمد
على المدى المسافه التي تكون
تقع فيها هذه القوات خلف الحدود لانه
القاعده الاساسيه التي تستخدم ثلثين وثلث
اي ثلث في اراضي الدوله المستخدمه وثلثي
المسافه او المدى في اراضي الدوله
المقابله البريطانيا المانيا فرنسا لواء
فايز تحدث يعني المعلومات جاءت بان هذه
الصواريخ سيجري استخدامها لاستهداف مواقع
القياده والمخازن في خلف الخطوط الاماميه
الروسيه هل
الخلف الخطوط الاماميه الروسيه هذه
المواقع هي بحاجه لمثل هذه الصواريخ من
وجهه نظر عسكريه
الان نتحدث عن المدى ولكن السؤال هل يسمح
لها باستخدامها خارج الاراضي المحتله وفقا
للقوانين الدوليه امريكا امريكا
اوضحت ذلك بالمطلق اذا هذه الصواريخ
ستستخدم ضمن اطار المناطق شرق اوكرانيا
وتحديدا شبه جزيره القرم لانه شبه جزيره
القرم الان تهاجم اما بصواريخ
شادوستورم جو ارض او تستخدم بالطائرات
المسيره او
بالزوارق المسيره او من قبل الضفادع
البشريه في هذه الحاله اذا ما تم التزويد
لا يمكن استخدامها من خلف نهر الدينيبر
بمسافه كبيره لانه الان نتحدث عن مسافه
مستقيمه مسافه جو ارض وبالتالي تصبح شبه
جزيره القرم ضمن متناول اليد وشبه جزيره
القرن من بعد ولكن شاهدنا اليوم لواء فايز
استهداف لميناء مقر القياده قياده الاسطول
البحريه الروسيه هناك بالطريقه دقيقه من
خلال صواريخ ايضا
وتابعنا ردود الفعل عليها اذا بالتالي
يعني استهداف شبه جزيره القرم هو تحصيل
حاصل ويتم في هذا التوقيت
نعم ولكن استخدام لاحظي بمسافات زمنيه
متباينه متقطعه وليست دائما باستخدام
صواريخ ظل العاصفه انما معظم الهجمات هي
بالطائرات في حال توفر صواريخ اتكامس
وتطلق هي صواريخ ارض ارض ومداهم 250 كيلو
متر الان امكانيه اطلاقها تكون من زوايا
مختلفه في توقيتات مختلفه بكثافه اكبر من
السابق بمعنى اخر انما سمها ستحدثه من
اضرار على الجانب الروسي سيكون اكبر بصوره
واضحه جدا مما يمكن تحقيقه في هذه الفتره
يضاف الى ذلك ان معدل استهلاك الذخيره
كبير جدا من قبل الجانب الاوكراني حتى ان
بولندا بدات تعيد حساباتها في تزويد
اوكرانيا بالذخائر والاسلحه لانها تقول
يجب ان اعمل موازنه ما بين المحافظه على
القدرات القتاليه للجيش البولندي
وارسال
ما يمكن ارساله الى الجانب الاوكراني اذا
في هذه الحاله عندما يتم تزويدها ببطاريات
اتى كامز يجب ان تزود بصواريخ مما يعني
زياده في المخزون شكرا جزيلا لك لواء فايز
الدويريه الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
حدثنا من عمان